quand on parle de malédiction là c'est
la l'incarnation même d'une
injustice malédiction tout ce que tout
ce qu'on veut
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle kawtar et je suis
la réalisatrice du film Les Filles
d'olfa ici à Cannes en compétition
officielle
[Musique]
alors l'élément déclencheur c'était en
2016 j'ai écouté à la radio une émission
on a invité Olfa qui parlait de ses
filles et j'ai trouvé le personnage
extraordinaire donc je me suis dit
j'aimerais bien faire un film avec elle
et avis cette histoire tragique de ses
filles que j'ai trouvé incroyable parce
qu'elle représente tous les thèmes qui
m'intéressent l'adolescence la maternité
la transmission de mère en fille les
traumatismes du coup j'ai appelé le
journaliste il m'a donné son numéro et
j'ai appelé Olfa je lui dis j'aimerais
bien faire un film avec vous
[Musique]
tout ce qui m'intéressait a eu déjà lieu
c'était le passé donc c'était une
affaire de souvenirs comment reconvoquer
les souvenirs d'une manière
cinématographique et là la fiction m'a
beaucoup aidé donc je faisais un
documentaire mais en utilisant les
outils de la fiction donc j'ai ramené
des comédiennes et j'ai demandé à Olfa
et ses filles de diriger les comédiennes
pour convoquer ses souvenirs j'ai créé
une espèce de dispositif où il y avait
un dialogue où on jouait la scène et on
réfléchissait aussi sur la scène la
nature du souvenir et ça signification
[Musique]
elles sont en Libye elles viennent
d'être jugées de saison de prison mais
elles sont pas seuls il y a la fille de
rofrane qui avec elle qui rentrait en
prison avec elle à l'âge du 5 mois
aujourd'hui elle a 8 ans donc c'est une
fille qui a grandi en prison donc
quand on parle de malédiction là c'est
la l'incarnation même d'une
injustice malédiction tout ce que tout
ce qu'on veut
[Musique]
ça m'a fait énormément plaisir de faire
revenir la Tunisie à la compétition
officielle avec des noms incroyables
quand même des gens quand j'ai commencé
à vouloir faire du cinéma que l'autre
c'était un Dieu pour moi quand je vois
cette personne voilà la liste est longue
et c'est énorme
[Musique]